lapine Renta ville finlandaise proche de
la frontière a toujours attiré les
Russes
à côté de la plus ancienne église
orthodoxe du pays le café major SCA Mel
culture et souvenir des deux voisins
Tanya une finlandaise dirige la branche
locale de l'Association d'Amitié fine
aux Russes un travail compliqué avec la
guerre en Ukraine
notre association fine russe a pensé à
changer de nom car certains en Finlande
ne veulent plus travailler avec nous
parce que notre nom indique un lien avec
la Russie
son organisation a condamné l'invasion
de l'Ukraine methania a été interrogé
par les services de renseignement
le pays est sur ses gardes des tracts de
possibles espions
à Helsinki les habitants de kepila se
retrouvent pour la fête du quartier
un moment de partage autour de plein et
de musique traditionnelles
sur le stand de l'Association d'Amitié
fino russe des livres et des jeux les
liens culturels sont à l'honneur pas la
politique
il n'est pas fan de la Russie non pas du
tout
avant j'étais plutôt anti russe
maintenant encore plus
je considère désormais que le régime
n'est pas le seul responsable
la population russe est aussi car le
pays c'est le peuple
il y a aussi des Russes
qui font la guerre eux je les soutiens
bien sûr ça c'est bien
de nombreux finlandais pensent que seuls
la fermeté est efficace face à Moscou
on ne peut pas leur faire confiance
c'est ça le problème
nous attaque j'imagine qu'on viendra
nous aider
on a notre armée à nous mais vous savez
c'est un grand pays on a perdu la
dernière guerre contre eux
l'invasion russe en Ukraine a été vécue
comme un véritable électrochoc par les
finlandais la méfiance est grande
vis-à-vis du puissant voisin russe avec
l'adhésion à l'OTAN les gens ont vu une
page de leur histoire se tourner avec la
fin d'une neutralité qui aura duré des
décennies